♪♪
-May! Alright, alright, come on.
We can't stay here.
We gotta get out of this place.
We gotta move fast.
You gotta hold my hand
and move exactly where I move.
Okay?
-Okay.
-Now come on, come on.
Gotta avoid the lights.
Now this way, this way. Come on.
Come on. Keep moving!
-We're back with Kurt
and Wyatt Russell.
Another clip from "Monarch."
So...
People who haven't watched
the show might not know
from the clip,
you play the same character
at different parts
of your life in the show,
so you actually didn't get
to shoot any scenes together?
-No.
-We shot one,
but it was not used.
-That's right.
-No chemistry?
"They just don't
seem like they like each other."
[ Laughter ]
And did you -- Was it pitched
to you guys as,
"hey, you know,
obviously this makes sense.
You look enough
alike that it would make sense
that you'd be two people
in different times"?
-Yeah. We have the same agent,
and he called and he was like,
"Hey, you know, this is an idea.
Ran across the casting director,
said, you know,
had this great idea."
And so we sort of thought,
"I don't know, maybe.
Yeah, maybe it could be.
It could be the worst idea
of all time, too."
As we went down
the rabbit hole, you know,
we started thinking
might be a good idea.
-Yeah. We did.
We'd had the opportunity
to play a father and son before.
Nothing really struck our fancy.
And, you know, just because
we're all -- in our family,
a lot of us are
in the same business,
and we just kind of go down
our own paths.
But yet, I think everybody
in the family,
we'd all like to work with each
other at some time or another.
And this was a different kind
of an opportunity to be able
to play the same person.
It was also very challenging
because you're not playing
father and son,
you're playing
the same person.
And I found myself
going down to Wyatt's set,
watching him.
And I realized, yeah,
this is interesting.
I stopped watching Wyatt
and I started
just watching the actor,
and I said,
"This guy is good, man."
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks, Dad.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Bet your dad
called you 'Tiger.'"
But I said, you know.
"Yeah, I got to
see what he's doing here
and kind of continue it on many,
many, many years later."
-It was cool because,
like, we've been asked a lot,
"What did you learn about your
dad" or "what did your dad --"
It's like, well, I didn't really
learn anything about my dad
because all I ever knew
was my dad,
and he's the truth teller.
He tells me the truth.
It's really boring.
But, like, it's the way life is.
And it's amazing for me
because I never had
to second-guess things.
And all I ever remember
is he was doing "Tombstone"
and there was a room,
a hotel room.
We were -- I was there for
probably three weeks maybe.
-Were you nine years old?
-Seven.
-And there was a couch,
and he put me to sleep
on the couch.
It was like 3 a.m.,
and they'd gotten done
with a long day of shooting.
He goes, smoking cigarets
at the table, starts writing,
and he was like writing
for a couple hours.
Then he'd go to sleep, wake up,
and I was like,
"Oh, I guess that's what you do
when you work.
You smoke cigarettes and write."
[ Laughter ]
And so all I ever knew
was the passion and energy
that he brought to it.
And seeing other people
get to see this now,
at his age,
which is a very youthful 47...
[ Laughter ]
...that, like, it was just
really cool for me
to see like people go, "Oh, wow,
holy S-H-I-T.
Kurt Russell really
is the real deal."
-Yeah.
-That was cool for me.
-That's really awesome.
And one of the nice things
about this,
sometimes press
is hard for actors,
but because you didn't shoot
together, this is the nice part.
You actually get to go out
and hang out.
-This is the most time we've got
to spend with each other
since he was playing hockey
and in Vancouver,
even before he went -- long
before he went into college.
-So you you were both
Kurt Russell,
the actor, and a hockey dad
at the same time,
which is a real job.
-I was a good hockey dad.
I was a very bad baseball dad.
-Okay, interesting.
-But I was a good hockey dad
because I didn't know that game.
I loved the game.
And my only wish
and hope for him
was that he wouldn't become
a goaltender.
-Yeah.
-And I think it was the third
time he stepped on the ice.
He was about 4 or 5.
The coach looks up to me
and goes,
"He wants to put the pads on."
I said, "No, man."
[ Laughter ]
"Just let him skate out
and have some fun."
-Can't lose if you
don't get scored on.
-That's what he said.
The next thing I know,
the rest of the team's
down there.
He's standing in front
of the goaltender,
keeping that puck
out of the net.
So he was born to get
in the net.
-My dad never missed a game.
-That's fantastic.
-It was awesome.
-I would miss so many.
[ Laughter ]
I hope they get into sports
just so I can miss them.
-Goldie made every one too.
I'll tell you what.
-Oh, God love her.
Another thing
about a show like this,
you know, obviously,
it's sci-fi,
a lot of special effects.
You do the work as actors.
You must feel good
about what you do.
And then you must have
felt so good
when you actually saw
the finished product.
And because, again,
you don't get to have
the benefit of the final effects
until you see it.
It must have been so exciting.
-It was very exciting
and also very just affirming
because in my head
I was always going,
"Well, if I suck, the monsters
are going to be sick."
You know, the monsters
are going to be awesome
and that's the backstop.
And then as you start
watching it, you're like,
"I hope the monsters are good
because I wasn't that good
in that scene."
[ Laughter ]
Watching with a critical eye.
But Apple was never going
to let it be anything but great.
And so I always had
a lot of fun.
-Yeah. It is fun
to see the outcome of it,
especially now -- What is it?
Friday the last one's on.
And it's got a -- 8, 9, and 10
are bang-up finish on this thing
and it's got a great last shot.
-Great ending.
-It's got a great ending on it.
-Really does have
a great last shot.
-I can't wait to see it.
Thank you guys for being --
What a joy to have you
both together.
-Thank you.
-Hey, man, thanks for this.
It's very sweet.
-Thank you, guys.
That's Kurt Russell,
Wyatt Russell.
Season finale of "Monarch"
this Friday, January 12th on
Apple TV+.
"Night Swim," fantastic.
-Oh, yeah.
-In theaters now.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with David Chase.